Thank you for coming to our
most recent NASA Google talk.
Today we have a Piramal PK
as he's known casually, um,
to talk about drones.
Hormel is the manager of the
safe operations autonomous
systems unit at ames.
He's been there for about 13 years and
he holds degrees in both industrial and
production engineering. Is that correct?
Okay, great. Without further ado,
I'd like to give it the stage over to PK.
Thank you.
Thank you for inviting me. This is
a great privilege to be here. Uh,
I had a wonderful Google
lunch that everybody talks
about, so that was nice. Um,
today I'm going to talk to you about how
we can enable safely enable large scale
uas operations in the loyalty
to their space. As you know,
there is a lot of excitement going on
in the drone industry and I know Google
and many other companies are working on
basically drones and drone applications.
And our goal is to try to enable the
entire industry in a safe manner.
So let's, before we start to
look at the future of aviation,
let's look at the current evaluation
system and how the aircraft operate in the
national airspace system.
What we referred to as Nass.
This animation displays air
traffic over the United States.
It was created using real air traffic
data from the Federal Aviation
Administration.
The animation starts at 8:00 PM and ends
at 8:00 PM eastern time the following
day late in the evening.
Uh,
Russia flights can be seen
departing for European destinations.
Quite a few aircraft are still seen
flying between the west coast airports.
In the middle of the night the skies are
clear and the number of aircraft drops
below 900.
Notice the red eye transcontinental
flights headed to the east coast.
Around 5:00 AM flights are seeing
departing from Memphis, a hub for FedEx.
As the day dawns traffic starts to build
up on the east coast at 8:00 AM half of
the country is bubbling with traffic
while the other half is still sleeping,
flights are seeing moving westward in
the airspace gets populated with aircraft
across the country.
As the day progresses around 11:00 AM a
steady stream of arrivals is seen coming
across the Atlantic Ocean.
The various airline hubs can
be seen throughout the day.
A hub can be identified by the
density of aircraft around it.
The two holes scene in the
triangle between San Francisco,
Los Angeles and Salt Lake City.
Our military operation areas and civilian
aircraft are forbidden to fly through
them in the middle of the day.
The number of aircraft peak just over
5,000 the animation shows the congested
northeastern part of the United States
and the complexity of the air traffic
management problem.
This animation displays air traffic and
weather over the northeastern part of
the United States.
In the beginning the flow is smooth but
when severe weather strikes around 9:30
AM the airports can't handle the arrivals.
Many aircraft are seen holding in the
air shown by the race track patterns of
blue lines which represent trails of
aircraft arriving at four New York area
airports.
Several aircraft are seen deviating
around severe weather and flying through
gaps between storm systems.
Many aircraft usually
flying along the east coast.
We're directed to fly over the Atlantic
Ocean to reach their New York area
destinations on this day
of significant delays,
weather impacted arrival traffic
for more than seven hours,
whether is the main cause of all delays
of air traffic in the United States.
So let's talk about the two animation.
The first animation actually shows the
complexity in the national airspace
system as it exists today.
There are 50,000 operations in a day,
about 5,000 at the peak time.
Um,
if you postulate the future
with drones operating that,
those numbers that you just saw,
we'll compare really,
really small with as compared with what
we are expecting to happen in the future.
So we really need some way
to organize this traffic.
The second animation that assured us
that the complexity increases as soon as
the weather actually happens to come
in the national airspace system.
So as soon as you experienced the weather,
we have tremendous delays and lots
of impact in the airspace system.
Now if we start to look at the future for
those who have gone to India and other
places or have seen these pictures from
the past can postulate and relate to
this, that when you start to have
number of new entrants on the road,
all of a sudden you realize that you need
some way to organize them because the
complexity is gone up and you have
different interests and different types of
operations happening and the and without
some kind of organization you are going
to have a trade off between
efficiency and safety.
So all of sudden you realize that let's,
let's make sure that we have some
way to organize this traffic.
What happened in 1956 is two aircraft
collided or Grand Canyon and that started
the air transportation system
and a traffic management system.
1958 when [inaudible] was born
at the same time NASA was born.
So what we are trying to do is get ahead
of that and come up with a system that
will allow us to enable safely enable
large scale drone operations or the low
altitude currently the
loyalty to their space.
Typically College Class G space
is unregulated but not control.
So as soon as you start to pump in lots
of drones and other vehicles there,
we would like to see that they basically
operate harmoniously with each other,
helicopters, personnel, calf
cause as well as drones.
How do we do that?
So our near term goal is to basically
safely enable these operation as soon as
possible.
And the longterm goal is to accommodate
the complexity and increased basically
capacity that is expected
to happen in that airspace.
There are lots of applications of drones
that have been postulated of course
surveillance of key assets
like railroad and pipelines,
search and rescue, cargo
delivery, Uav helping,
ambulance taking pictures,
recreational activities and such.
So once you realize that there are a
number of these operations going to happen
at the same time, same place in the same
airspace, uh, then we really say that,
let's make sure that we have
some way to organize them.
So that's basically calling for a
persistent system at an airspace and a
geographical area as well as you look
at the board table system where you go
from one basically area to another
area area such as a disaster relief
applications or agriculture applications
where they are very confined due to
that geographical area or airspace.
So we are talking about two different
types of applications. Nonetheless,
the characteristics of enabling them
safely and harmoniously or the same
in terms of us traffic manager management.
We are really trying
to balance three goals.
First goal is national
and regional security.
We want to make sure that the drones
by the accidentally don't go where they
shouldn't go. Uh, such as uh, uh,
White House and Wall Street and,
and number of key assets on the ground
as well as we don't have rogue operators
that basically go and
create damage intentional.
So we have to worry about the national
and regional security. At the same time,
we are trying to make sure that we get
economic value of using the low altitude
using the drone applications. And
there are number of these applications,
commercial applications.
Uh,
as you saw agriculture application
as well as personal applications.
My personal draw,
my personal dream is that every home will
have a drone and every home will serve
as a error or drum sometime in the future.
So how do we enable that that needs
to be enabled through safe airspace
integration.
So the idea is to create flexible
digital virtual infrastructure.
So flexibility where possible
and structure where it's
necessary is one month
mantra.
And second is you match the geographical
needs applications with the performance
that's required to operate in that
airspace. So let's take each one of them.
So flexibility where possible.
So the idea is that you can go wherever
you want to go till the point where the
demand and capacity are off balance.
Then you may need some structures such
as corridors crossing restrictions or
altitude for direction. So it's completely
based on the demand and the capacity.
The second month, right here is the need
of the geography as well as application.
So here the context is that if you are
operating in the remote areas and your
application is you're doing surveillance,
you're never going to
get down to the ground.
Then the required performance on the
airspace operations on the vehicle as well
as airspace is different than you're
going to operate in the congested airspace
as well as near urban airspace and going
all the way to the down all the way to
the ground to the last and first 50 feet.
So the performance characteristics on the
vehicle and the type of capability you
need on the vehicle is different.
So we want to match the geography,
the risks involved with that as well
as the application with the required
performance to operate in that airspace.
So what is UTM question always comes,
what is UTM?
Utm sort of is a research prototype and
ideally what we are after is developing
the airspace operations
performance requirements
through this research prototype,
which will allow the operators
to basically submit flight plans,
tons of light plants at the same time,
and execute their missions
at the loyalty to operations.
He will also check to make sure
that there are no constraints,
they're not violating any constraints.
And we'll talk about what those look like.
At the same time,
we envision that these basically system
will consist of multiple airspace
providers, just like Internet
service, Reuters, Isp,
you could have multiple layers with
service providers that could interoperate
harmoniously in the same airspace.
So let's look at the functions of Utm.
The first function is airspace
operations in management.
So what is the boundary
of the low altitude?
So currently we envision
500 feet and below.
Obviously that's dependent on the type
of operations you want to conduct,
the types of missions as well as the
density. So you might want to change that.
But nonetheless,
at the moment we are envisioning that
400 feet and below there is no reason to
climb, to spend energy if
you don't have to. And again,
going back to the point we made before
that geographical needs and applications
will have to be coupled together.
So the rules for airspace will be based
on the performance and the geography
that's associated with that operation.
So this picture shows geo fences.
So there are two types of Geo Francis.
One is a static geo fence
such as basically White House
or in this case it shows
a stadium and a dynamic geo fence such as
wildfire affected area which moves over
time so that Geo fence changes over
time.
So you need to have constant update,
updated information about the Geo fences,
which who are the areas which are sort of
no fly zones or the aerospace to avoid.
The second function of Utm service would
be the wind and weather integration.
So the idea here is that the current
vehicles that operate in that area,
this airspace are largely
helicopters and gliders.
They have different
susceptibility to wins.
Then the 55 pound vehicle
that is going to operate here.
So we really need a lot finer grid and
more accurate forecast of the winds so
that we can actually show and make that
information available to all the users
to say which airspace is safe to fly,
which is not then congestion management.
As soon as we allow these operations,
we expect that demand and capacity could
get off balance in certain locations.
And once that happens,
then we need to have ways to manage that.
So obviously this is only needed type
of basically feature that it will create
corridors or altitude for direction and
any crossing restrictions based on the
demand and capacity imbalance.
The other feature of this
UTM is separation management.
Ideally you want all the separation and
collision management to occur on the way
called side til the point where we have
vehicles that get smart and can do its
own sense and avoid. There is no reason
necessarily to stop these operations.
We can initiate these operations
with number of different construct.
First construct it is space reservations
so you can actually file a trajectory
or flight plan and say,
okay,
this airspace is mine and
you complete your use case,
our mission and then
that is space gets open.
You can actually notify to the other
operators that I am operating in this
airspace.
I uh,
in the future obviously as the density
goes up, that is highly inefficient.
So we want to see some kind of vehicle
to vehicle sense and avoid and separation
management,
collision avoidance technologies.
And that could happen through sensors.
On board as well as connected systems
through Internet and what we call as we to
V and V to UTM systems,
much like autonomous cars.
One of the underpinnings of
that is tracking in the very
remote areas over water.
You may not need any tracking
because there is density is very low.
You gotta let them fly wherever they
want to fly and they closed the the
trajectory once their
operation is finished.
But as you get closer to the congested
airspace, highly constrained airspace,
closer to the Geo fence areas,
you want to have sophisticated tracking,
the number of options,
cell phone based tracking,
eight years be tracking it,
ESB based tracking as Satellite
Cube and k you when tracking.
So let's take one, uh, each option at
a time. The cell phone based tracking,
which is promising,
but currently only roughly 55% of
the land is code by cell phones.
So what do we do about
the rest eight years?
We automatic dependent surveillance base.
Broadcast tracking is also postulated,
which also shows promise,
however it has its own limitations.
Then the question is what is the best
way most persistent tracking mechanisms?
So some places you may need
combination of three cell phone,
satellite based as well as [inaudible]
tracking to make sure that we know
exactly where the vehicles are.
So the idea there is to make sure that
they do not cross geo fences where they
shouldn't go.
And uh,
another feature of the UTM is
contingency management. Obviously we,
the cost of entry into her space
is gone to zero with these drones,
which is really exciting because you
see lots of good applications. However,
it also poses some challenges
such as nine one, one,
it's possible conceivable that situations
like nine one one could be, uh,
could happen with drones.
So how do we actually tackle that?
So you really need to know that which
are the cooperative targets and which are
noncooperative targets.
So you may need a surveillance
system around high value assets.
We are also interested in making sure
that the large scale gps as well as cell
phone outage happens. And if that
happens, how do you actually manage that?
So where you call onboard vehicles
will have certain capabilities,
simultaneous localization and mapping
and then some kind of basically record
path and contingencies that says if you
lose everything then you had about your
basically trajectory and
land in a safe place.
This cartoon actually gives sort of
an idea what are the different steps
involved in submitting the flight plan.
Then checking through the UTM type of
services. Uh, and these are by the way,
not monolithic services.
So number of operators can have their
own UTM type of services and they can
connect with each other. Um, so
operator, we'll submit the, the,
the flight plan or trajectory.
It can be a scheduled one or it can be
on demand than it would system will check
for authentication,
make sure that the vehicle and
the operator is authenticated,
then it will check for
all the constraints.
It will check for static as
well as dynamic constraints.
We'll make sure that there
are no contingencies is, uh,
is going through the right air space
and it's not crossing any geo fences and
such. And then operate as
the operation is completed.
It will and the mission.
And the airspace will get open.
Okay.
Then we have four technical capabilities.
The way we envision going about
doing this. So it's missing this,
which is interesting.
But uh,
nonetheless we finished that
capability so it's less important.
We finished that demonstration.
So we are,
the way we go about doing this is
follow, crawl, walk, run strategy.
So the idea is each capability targets,
uh, different types of application,
geographical area and the,
and the risk associated with that.
So the first capability,
which we demonstrated
a in August this year,
last year included a special
reservation as the basic construct.
So you have trajectory planner,
you can file the trajectory,
it will check for all the constraints
and that airspace is yours till you close
that trajectory. And it uses either
airspace notification or aerospace,
the reservation as the construct to
notify the other operators where you are
operating. But that was focused
on within visual line of sight.
So the next capability and
the first capability really
targets the remote areas,
very low density operations over water
and such a precision agriculture or
things like that that operate in a very
remote areas will be supported by this
capability.
The second capability goes,
allows us to go beyond visual line of
sight and also offers tracking of these
vehicles through either cell phone,
eight ESB or satellite based Kau band,
uh, and again supports low density
operations, sparsely populated areas.
And there will be some basic rules when
there are a number of vehicles operating
at the same time in the same space.
Uh,
this will enable the longer
range applications because
it is going beyond visual
line of sight.
The third capability adds a separation
management component to that which allows
vehicle to vehicle or,
or very cold through
UTM connected systems,
either through internet
or some other means, uh,
which allows to have some
basic interaction with a
manned air vehicles as well
as unmanned systems.
So as I mentioned before,
this is the narrative space where you
see some helicopter operations. So,
so it's very critical that we have a
system that allows operators to keep away
from each other. Fundamentally, we
are after five basic principles.
The first principle is
drones don't hit each other.
Second principle is drones and manned
aviation stay away from each other.
Third one is drone operator has complete
awareness of all the constraints and
avoids all the constraints
in the airspace.
Fourth principle is drone all the
drone operator as well as the drones
themselves or authenticated.
And the fifth principle is drone operators
and drones basically give preference
to a public safety drones and public
safety manned aviation aviation.
So though using those principles,
then we go to the basically the subsequent
capabilities and the last capability,
which is the fourth capability that
allows you to operate in the urban high
density is a space where you really
need to worry about large scale
contingencies that we talked about before.
But this is where our vision is.
This is where everybody wants to go to
be able to go to the fourth capability
and allow lots of uses of
drones in the urban airspace.
Now the elegance of this approach is
that it is not monolithic system that you
had to actually apply the
entire system everywhere.
This is the way we have organized
this research prototype is in a, uh,
using cloud based services.
So multiple providers who would
basically offer different services.
You could have multiple operators will
pro, uh, just like I mentioned before,
Internet service providers,
you could have airspace service services
providers and they could connect with
each other through a common
application protocol interface.
So multiple providers could
offer similar services.
That could be some tailoring
of operational services
based on geographical area.
This picture basically shows that if you
are in a remote area or less congested
airspace,
you could get away with the build one or
technical capability level one type of
services. And if you are in a
very congested urban airspace,
you may need higher levels of technical
capabilities and requirements on the way
you call as well as aerospace operations.
So that shows you four,
which is ut on four class
of kind of airspace.
So the elegance again is to try to make
sure that you balance the services that
are needed based on the airspace
where you want to operate.
The risks on the ground as well as
the use case that you are after.
And vehicle performance and vehicle
characteristics needed across these four
technical capabilities is different.
Now the question comes who operates this
airspace and what's the right business
model.
Now different countries,
we have been in discussion with many
countries about how they think this will
evolve in each location and different
countries have different ways of
organizing the businesses
around this UTM construct.
So it could be a single service provider,
like a government entity.
Traditional is,
is based navigation services that could
provide the service or it could be
multiple service providers at the
local state or county levels, uh,
that could operate this.
Or it could be a single service provider,
but the non government entity,
or it could be multiple service providers
basically providing services to non
government entities so you can customize
and figure out how we can interoperate
with each other.
So that's sort of the basic idea of
there's different business models and as I
mentioned,
the different countries are actually
looking at different types of business
models and fee for service
kind of characterization.
Regardless the regulator will have a
key role in certifying the system and
operations and all cysts,
all UTM systems are there variations
who will interact with each other.
So what are the key technologies then,
you know,
the question always comes what's missing?
What are the barriers?
What are the key technologies
we still need to have?
Now these are 55 pound and
below type of vehicles.
So their ability to carry size,
weight,
power is somewhat limited.
So we really need to make sure that uh,
that,
that anything that you put on the vehicle
can sustain in terms of size, weight,
power and the cost. So first,
uh, capability, new technology,
key technology is a track and locate
and there could be a combination of the
things that we discussed. Cell phone eight
years be satellite based technologies,
a very small basically that can fit on
on the smaller way equal and Kerry and a
payload is small.
The power is a requirement is small,
but persistently in track we'll be able
to track the way he calls and their
location since an award. This
is an interesting problem. So,
uh, as you see sense and avoid
technologies evolving everywhere,
the ability to carry the sensor packs
on these vehicles is highly limited,
which actually offers a lot
of innovative approaches,
a lidar based and vision based
systems that actually have been tried.
And one of the key challenges is too
small objects such as these wires.
To be able to see these wires from farther
distance and to be able to basically
stay away from them is one of the
key challenges in the sense and avoid
technologies because these vehicles
are operating at the lower altitude.
Last and first 50 feet
operation autonomous operations
is another interesting
challenge.
So what happens is you ideally you want
these vehicles to operate completely
autonomously all the way to the doorstep.
Then the question comes,
how are you going to tackle the problem
where grandma is doing landscaping,
kids are running around with soccer ball
and um, there are pets running around.
So you need highly intelligent system.
On the vehicle itself that census any
obstacles along the way and basically
figure so what to do with it.
There are number of other approaches
which are not necessarily technical.
You could have a thread that drops the
basically what our package you are doing
a we're delivering is one way you
could have a chimney that's raised,
you could how your mailbox raised 10 feet.
But nonetheless in the future we would
like to see the last and first 50 feet
operation happening fully autonomously.
Whether sensing and production is another
interesting area where you need a lot
more refined where the
sensing and prediction,
particularly the wind in this airspace
so that the way you call itself can
actually take it or take advantage of
the information and figure out what's the
right path,
what's the right optimal path for that
particular use case and award the areas
that they should avoid. And as I
mentioned before, we see this as a,
one of the potential here is that
multiple service providers could actually
offer services for the operator.
So then the idea is to integrate them
through some common application protocol
interface.
In terms of progress,
what we are done so far is that we are
completed technical capability level one
we did demonstration
with 12 partners and the,
we are successfully shown that the basic
construct of airspace notification on
the reservation,
it could be adequate for
remote kind of areas, uh,
through the research.
Our next step is to basically
continue to evolve this prototype.
So we have been working
with very closely with FFA,
Department of Homeland
Security, Department of Defense,
Department of Interior.
We have something we referred to as
research transition team that collaborates
across the government entities.
We also have very tight coordination
and collaboration across industry and
academic circles.
We are over 125 collaborators
from industry as well as a career.
Uh, we developed the initial
concept to operations.
We demonstrated that we got a lot of
feedback from lots of stakeholders and we
continue to evolve this.
There has been many,
many basically discussions and and uh,
simulations as well as testing
of these construct. Uh,
we also released our
application protocol interface.
So anybody who wants to collaborate
with us gets a application protocol
interface that allows them to connect
their subsystems as well as the very
cooperations. Uh, as I mentioned,
technical capability level one test will
successfully completed and we have a
huge international interest.
We just got uh,
over six international entities that
are really interested in following the
construct of UTM across different
countries and figuring out how they can
benefit from using the construct UTM.
Our next steps.
Basically we'll continue to
evolve this construct of Utm,
particularly in going towards
high density urban airspace.
Uh,
we want to conduct,
develop a conductor and more research
on the sensors that we really need small
as small as we can get continuous
simulations and test these bills along the
way. We will also continue to work with
industry and other academy and government
groups to refine the concepts and our
assistant architectures are different ways
of organizing the data structures as
well as inter interacting with multiple
operators.
We have a prototype,
then we will continue to
evolve with that till we,
we are able to prove that
safe, um, integration, uh,
could occur everywhere.
We also have a national,
a initial campaign,
uh,
focused on creating the UTM kind of
structures are the FAA test sites and
allowing them to do for
the validation of the data.
Uh, I would like to show you
an animation of how this,
this system could work.
Yeah.
Any questions?
How do you think are terrorist
attack employing drones?
Would the impact development of
a UTM and [inaudible] in general?
Well, obviously, uh, any, any
terrorist attack is a attack is bad.
I need it does search us back. Uh, and,
and causes a pause like nine one one.
Um,
but, but I think that is, uh, the,
there are two, two answers to that.
One is that we shouldn't
stop progress. So, you know,
Asian will continue to
occur to a word that,
and second is there are
technologies already in,
in being developed that will detect
uncooperative targets and then figured out
what to do with them. But that's in
the law and order kind of situation.
So the idea here in the
UTM is to figure out, uh,
the,
a rogue operators or uncooperative objects
that are basically trespassing into
geo fence.
And that's where UTM stops.
And there are a number of technologies
are insane service and loyalty do radars
that you may have to have at certain
locations, key assets on the ground. Um,
but it could, it could set us
back, uh, but at the same time, uh,
this is the time to actually think through
and figure out what systems we need
to be a base we need to put in place to,
to avoid or prevent or basically
manage that kind of situation.
I'm kind of curious,
I was just listening to a podcast
on private plane and drone, um,
private companies that are
doing surveillance and a
lot of the problems they
were coming up against were um,
just public opinion and people like,
uh, in cities voting down,
wanting to have that around them.
So just curious what efforts you
guys have going in that direction.
Yeah, so, uh,
that's a good question and we collaborated
on with many entities are a number of
things. And so the one of the, of the,
the basically our thrust is technical
aerospace operation performance
requirements. So developing that side
of requirements is what we are after.
Obviously we understand the,
the barriers are lack of
these technical requirements.
Second is a privacy consideration.
Security considerations as
the previous question. Uh,
public acceptance and policies.
Uh,
we at NASA or not, we are not
working on that particular problem,
but we are collaborating with
number of other entities.
I've heard it as well as non entities to
figure out what is the right way to do
that.
Uh,
in your slide with the business models,
you kind of had different
quadrants of one,
one service provider to rule them
all and then a federated system. Um,
in your discussions in particular,
I'm interested in international
discussions of are the
people falling into that
quadrant somewhere where
they're comfortable?
Yeah, I think, uh, there are
certain countries who are, uh,
who have prioritize operations already,
airspace management ATM. Uh, so they,
they have a preference for different
quarter than some other countries.
So I think really what they are familiar
with, what their safety record is,
what their density of operations and
complexities, we'll make them comfortable.
So different actually quadrons appeal
to different countries based on that.
And then the amount of investment that's
needed. So that's a great question, but,
uh,
it's,
it's fortunately one size fits
all is not what we are after.
We are basically allowing the
cloud based architecture to,
to go in any direction, any quarter
and that a country wants to go.
The system is w should be flexible
enough to offer any of these services.
Uh, we've seen a lot of innovation
in UAV over the last few years.
Where do you see hobbyists and startups
falling not just as aviators but as
one's developing control
systems in vehicles?
You are, I think it's been
great. No, I thank you. Uh,
I think it has been great
and mean because of the,
the number of innovators that have entered
into this traditional as well as non
traditional aviation companies.
We have seen very rapid development
towards sense and avoid technologies
tracking and locating things and as
well as a assured autonomy for last and
first 50 feet. We are in saw all
the problems, but I think we are,
because of the collaboration we have
with number of entities and the interest
that,
uh,
that exist and the funding that's gone
into this is unprecedented. I think,
you know, so I see this as a
great sign for aviation. It,
it's really exciting to be aviator again.
You know,
do we expect to see carve outs in the
air space for people to develop these new
systems or will they have to Polish it,
you know,
indoors before it can be released
into the water air space.
Do you, what was the first
sentence, do you see what
a carve out in the air space for people
who are developing new vehicles and new
control systems for vehicles?
Oh yeah.
I think there's a lot already.
There are a number of companies
that are developing new systems for,
some of them are developing operating
system for autonomous systems on their
control, new control systems.
So I see a lot of opportunity.
Yeah.
And if you have ideas we obviously
would like to work with you.
Okay.
So coming at it from a position of being
a private pilot,
I'm curious your take on how much of
getting this right depends on placing
restrictions that don't exist today
on aircraft. On current aircraft,
like the,
there's no reason for instance,
that other than not having a commercial
license that I can't go fly a crop
duster out a couple hundred feet off
the ground at very high speeds. Uh,
and then you clear a UAV to
fly through my field, uh,
because all of that is
unregulated right now. Uh,
and the same for helicopters and
sightseeing flights and other things.
So it was given that we don't file these
detailed flight plans and get reserved
airspace, uh, for all of
those sorts of operations.
How do we fit uas into all of that?
No, that's a good question. Right. So, uh,
and there are probably different answers
depending on location and their density.
Currently the space is regulated but
not control the clause years is where
general aviation largely occurs.
And Yeah,
they are not required to file a flight
plan or trajectories, but some of them do.
So one option is that you
have, uh, basically, uh,
the drone operators while trajectories
and through network system,
everybody has access to that information.
So even before you take off as a
general elevator, you have, you know,
information as to where the drones
are likely to operate. You know, uh,
other one is basically very tactical,
where both have some kind of way
to coordinate with each other.
We two weeks systems that are evolving
now and keep away from each other. Right?
So it's really a function
of density and what kind of,
uh,
our risks we want to mitigate.
If there's a huge amount of drone
operations going on, same airspace,
obviously you would like to
know that and vice versa. So,
um, to the, to the same effective,
if that would basically mean that
in order to avoid hitting drones,
you would either by
regulation or by, uh, uh,
preservation of life need to get
additional equipment for your aircraft.
All right,
so the,
I think technology first as my bias,
I,
we try to figure out if we can solve this
problem through technology. You know,
obviously there is always the
regulatory aspect. Uh, and,
and that's something that FIS has
to, I mean, you know, think deep,
but, uh, if we can come up with this is
where the innovation, the prior question,
where is the innovation?
This is where one of the possibilities
where we could actually collaboratively
in a way it's something that will actually
help the entire aviation industry.
So the schedule for rolling out,
you had a slide,
the first one was empty and
then you had three more. Uh,
it's a fairly aggressive schedule.
Um,
and you mentioned some technologies that
we're going to be potentially use like
slam, which is a very, um, early, um,
very challenging of
David technology to use.
So how do you feel that the
pace of technology and I'm
like processing power and
battery and all those things is going to
look in the next five years compared to
the types of regulation that we'd like
to be able to enforce? Yeah.
So the schedule that you saw,
um,
I should clarify that that's not
a rollout schedule for operations.
That's where we would like to do the test
to understand that require marriage to
operate in the rollout schedule.
Obviously just not up to NASA.
It's really about making sure that we
have all the other issues, you know,
as a previous boss and ask about privacy
in public policy and then making sure
that the FAA has the
regulatory structure in place.
So the rollout schedule will depend
on a lot of other factors then what he
showed. But the slam, I'm going back to
your question about the slam technology.
I think, uh, we are hoping that in
four years we are working on some,
uh,
aggressively as well as you guys and
many others on science and award and slam
technology.
So we are hoping that by 2019 we will
have a reasonable prototype technology.
So that's sort of our goal is to try to
push ourselves to get to that point. Um,
is it a risk in that?
Yeah,
it's possible that we may
not get completely a hundred
percent accurate by then,
but I think the goal current indicators
are that we are migrating towards that.
So anyhow,
have thoughts on particular risks in the
technologies or things that we should
be looking at?
Obviously we are open to that.
Uh,
at the moment we were already seeing a
proliferation of radio technologies with
General Aviation, like you have your
uit transmitters and the 10 90 band. Um,
do we expect, um, UAVs
and drones to have, um,
multiple radio technologies
to communicate or, you know,
will we just rely on a
central point to coordinate?
Yeah, that's a good
question. So we are, uh,
we are exploring a number of,
uh,
aviation grid as well as currently non
aviation approved technologies like cell
phone based technologies. So, um, you,
what you mentioned about be on the UAT
and UAT technologies of frequencies are
possible there one candidates,
but then they could be cell
phone based possibilities.
So we are exploring that
as well. Uh, we don't,
we don't know exactly how this will a
wall, whether it will consist of multiple,
multiple technologies for
the same platform based on
the altitude or location or
all of them may evolve differently.
Thank you so much.